and now here are the nominees for
original screenplay
mikail Chanukah one more Quentin
Tarantino for Django Unchained John
guidance for flight Wes Anderson and
Roman Coppola for moonrise kingdom
mark Bowe four zero dark thirty and the
Oscar goes to mr. Tarantino
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
category for fiction
that's cool Shelley's is my neighbor not
very nice to get this review Thank You
mr. Hoffman boy oh boy you know I've
been saying things like I wanted you to
think the actors for what they've done
when it comes to my script but and it's
it's not just a easy thing to say it
really is why I'm standing here I
actually think if people are like
knowing about my movies 30 or 50 years
from now it's gonna be because of the
characters that I created and I really
only got one chance to get it right I
have to cast the right people to make
those characters come alive and
hopefully live for a long time and boy
this time did I do it thank you so much
guys Leonie over there but I'm thinking
him too
[Music]
okay I know I'm getting off on getting
up but one last thing I would like to
say that it's such an honor to get it
this year because I have to say in both
the original and the adapted categories
the writing is just fantastic this will
be the writers year Matt thank you very
much I love this part I love the
competition you guys are all wonderful
peace out